True. Excuse me, is he standing here?
Yeah, yeah, okay. I need to go back.
Yes, go ahead. On one condition, you
list you listening to me.
Yes,
that we do not interrupt each other. The
moment we start interrupting each other,
the conversation is over. All right?
Okay.
>> You get it? This condition I will accept
but with another condition.
That is as long as you answer the
question.
Yeah, but how do you define who defines
>> Because Alhamdulillah, we me people know
me a lot. Alhamdulillah. They know about
me. My question is simple. Clearly, if I
ask you
There there there there there there is
simple question I'm going to ask you.
Can you go back? Can you go back?
Because I'm I'm I'm surrounded like
that. Yeah, yeah.
And he is standing here. He is blocking
it.
>> He has he has all the right to say Yeah,
yeah, he came before us. Yeah.
Yeah, he came before us. But why are you
Catholic or born again cuz I see you
fighting?
I don't know. They say you're not
Christian.
What did they say you're not Christian?
But they say you're not Christian. He's
not Christian and Orlando is not
Christian. Orlando is not Christian? Oh,
okay.
Okay.
And then there's a guy.
Are we interrupting each other? Are we
not interrupting each other? No, as long
as you are you answer the question. I
know I know. Let me tell you one thing.
No no no offense to you. I know nothing
about you. You know nothing about me,
right? I have already in the minute that
I've been standing here warned by at
least three people that I shouldn't be
talking to you because the conversation
is not going to be fruitful. So so
now having having said that
if if
we're going to interrupt each other, if
you're not going to let me answer your
questions or whatever you want to say,
the conversation will be over
immediately. Okay.
>> that? All right. So like I said to you,
you can see clearly you were speaking
and I didn't interrupt you tonight. I
didn't. Okay? So, I believe those who
warned you because they want you to
maybe hear the truth. They want to
control and manipulate you. But you're a
big man and you can see you're a smart
man, inshallah. So, you see you're
interrupting me now cuz I have to let
you speak. Okay?
Yeah, no, no, but I I you have to let me
finish. When you speak, I didn't
interrupt you. Yeah. So, what I'm saying
to you, like I said, as long that we're
going to ask the questions, okay? Then
no problem. Cuz now if you ask me about
Prophet Muhammad and let's say I'm
speaking about Manchester United, then
when you try to interrupt me, you say,
"Shamsi, ask the question." I said,
"Don't interrupt me." Then this is going
to become like a game. But I hope you
sincerely seeking the truth or you won't
accept the truth cuz I believe what you
have is not the truth and I believe I
have the absolute truth with me. So, I'm
here to call you to the truth
respectfully. You understand? So, now if
you want to start this question, my
discussion is about You accept Do you
believe Jesus as God?
I believe what the apostles believed
what all early Christians believed in
the first century, in the second
century, in the third century, in the
fourth century. This is what I believe.
So, I believe what the church had
believed for the past 2,000 years. That
the Lord Jesus Christ is God incarnate.
Who God manifest God who became flesh
for our salvation.
So, you believe See, you could have
answered by saying, "Yes, I believe
Jesus is God." But you went on, "I
believe what the apostles believe, what
these believe, what I believe." You
could have just summarized by saying,
"Yes, I believe Jesus is God." If you
believe Jesus is God, then what
differentiate Islam from any religion
that Islam goes along our sound
intellect. Sound intellect. Regardless
if you're a Christian or Muslim. You
know, there's something called a law of
a law of contradiction. Meaning that
there's certain things you and I we
agree doesn't make any sense. However,
some of us, due to our belief, what
we're going to do, we're going to start
to wrestle in our our own intellect for
this
even though we know
logically, rationally, you know, with
the rational, doesn't make any sense.
You said you believe God incarnate,
correct? Okay, well, first of all, I
want to comment
>> Okay, if you believe God incarnate,
was that the father or Jesus? If you say
it's not the father, it's Jesus,
therefore you don't believe in one God.
Also,
God is perfect, there's no change in
nature. And you got nothing is greater
than God. And you believe that
the Mary Mary was bigger than your God,
then this is a problem that Do you agree
with this 2,000 years ago?
>> First of all, I want to comment on what
has just been said about the intellect
and Islam being the religion that
promotes intellect. This is not about
intellect, this is about faith and what
we believe. Because my friend here
chooses to believe what he believes. He
chooses to follow
his companions. I, on the other hand,
choose to follow the Lord Jesus Christ
and his apostles. So, the Lord Jesus
Christ came and preached what the
prophets preached before, and then he
reaffirmed that he had given the new
teaching, the teaching that was above
every teaching in this world, and
remains to be above every teaching in
this world, no exception. And he had
passed this teaching, he had given it to
his disciples, he preached in Palestine
in the Holy Land, and then the apostles,
they would ordain their heirs, and their
heirs would ordain their heirs, and this
is how the church has survived and has
lived in the past 2,000 years. So, this
is not about intellect, this is about
trust. I trust the Lord Jesus Christ, I
trust his apostles, I trust all those
who have been following the Lord Jesus
Christ for the past 2,000 years. And
there is nothing that would convince me
as a Christian to all of a sudden
apostatize and step away from the
teaching of the Lord Jesus Christ to
accept something that came several
centuries later, and that, most
importantly, has no connection
whatsoever, neither with the Lord Jesus
Christ, nor with his apostles, nor with
the prophets, nor with the biblical
revelation, nor with God himself. So,
okay. So, now that I've said that this
is not about intellect. And by the way,
our intellect, I think we can all agree,
is flawed. So, we can One can be an
intellectual and not believe in God. One
can be an intellectual and believe in
something nonsensical, right? So,
So, this is not about intellect first
and foremost. This is about what God had
revealed to us. So, when I said that I
believe in what the apostles preach,
apostolic church had believed Check the
time, please.
Check the time.
I meant was not that I don't rely on
intellect. I meant that it is
All right. So, it's based on this
foundation that I can now respond to
your second question. Do I believe that
the Lord Jesus Christ is God? Of course,
he is God because this is what the what
all of us
That was not my question.
Now, is he Was it the Father who was
incarnate? Was it the Son? Was it the
Holy Spirit? This is the kind of
question type of question that
presupposes
that lack of understanding of what we as
Christians believe about the Holy
Trinity. So, of course, we as
Christians, we believe that was the word
of God, the second person of the
Trinity, the eternal Logos, the wisdom
of the power of God as the Lord the the
scripture calls it.
He took on upon himself our human
nature. So, he became human being for
the sake of our salvation, and then he
lived a perfect life. He suffered on the
cross for our sake, and he rose again on
the third day so that all of your sins
could be forgiven if you believe in the
Lord Jesus Christ, God incarnate. Right?
So, it's the second person
>> Believe in it. If he says no, I say why
you say this cannot be God. If he say
I'm going to utilize my intellect, I say
hang on. You just said you cannot
utilize intellect. It's about faith. So
he will contradict himself. And this is
why Christianity is dying. That's why
churches in Europe are turning into
nightclubs and swimming pools and we're
buying them turning them into mosques
because the Christians are leaving
Christianity. The fact you can tell
someone who has PhD, do not use your
intellect which God gave you. When God
sent down revelation in order for me to
know the person who's claiming that he
received revelation from God is from God
or not, I have to use what? I have to
use my intellect, my sound reasoning.
Otherwise, the Hindus, they can say same
thing. Believe in what Hinduism teaches
or Hinduism teaches and do not use your
brain. It's about faith. That's why the
Quran, that's why Islam is spreading
where in the Western world when there is
a big big Islamic phobia, BIG PROPAGANDA
against Islam. And we know the Western
world, THEY HAVE STRONGER weapons in
terms of social media to utilize to turn
people away from Islam. Yet Islam is
spreading in the Western world.
Likewise, some of us because this prince
here, he just proved the Muslims points
that the Christianity is not about
intellect, it's about blind faith. The
other things I want to mention, I asked
him simply, when you believe that Jesus
became God became his son, WAS THAT THE
FATHER OR NOT? And how many gods?
Because if you you believe Jesus is not
the father if you because if you believe
Jesus is the father, some of the cameras
they would turn off. Some Christians,
they would turn off their cameras
because that is a heresy. So therefore
there's two gods. If they say no,
THERE'S ONLY ONE GOD, SAY OKAY, who
became a man? THE FATHER or the son? If
they say the son, then the father never
became a man. So, there's two gods. One
became a man, one never became a man.
No, no, there's only two gods. THERE'S A
THREE GOD, THE HOLY SPIRIT. Then they
say we BELIEVE IN ONE GOD, and and we
have to excuse them. Why? No, excuse
them means that it's a valid excuse, but
it's not valid excuse before Allah. What
is we have to understand, if he already
established to his listeners, to the
viewers, to the Christians, that we
don't have to we don't have to use
intellect anymore. Therefore, and now,
if you believe three in one, one in
three, one one god is greater than
greater than THE OTHER GOD, GOD never
become a baby, but God become a baby.
Of course, if the Christians going to
question this belief, he's going to
answer by saying, "No, don't know use
your brain. Don't use intellect, it's
about faith." Like I said, this
Christian this why Christianity is
dying. And you can see he died dressed
by talking about why Jesus died for our
sins, as he believes, and so on. The
point here we want to discuss the most
important topic about the oneness of
God.
Is Jesus God? Do you believe in one god
or three gods? So, please, we don't
digress by saying you know, I have to
answer your question this and that.
Let's go back to the main point. I want
to show to the Christians, you don't
believe in one god. You believe in three
gods, and you believe that your god was
weaker, people was powerful than him. He
was breastfed, someone changes his
nappy. I'm not mocking you, by the way,
cuz how to mock? I'm just stating what
you believe. And by Allah himself, if I
take him to the
and I show HIM A NEW BABY, AND SOMEONE
CHANGES HIS NAPPY, CLEAN his poo, AND HE
SAID THIS IS GOD, I THINK HE WILL SMACK
ME.
SO, CHRISTIANS, when you look at Islamic
teaching,
Allah describe himself, "Qul hu Allahu
Ahad." Say Allah is one. "Allahu Samad."
Master, self-sufficient. "Lam yalid
walam yu" Meaning, he's not in need of
anything. Everything is in need of him.
He beget not neither was he begotten.
There is nothing like unto Allah. Allah
is not in need
to commit suicide
to forgive your sins. Allah is the most
merciful regardless how much sins you
commit.
ALLAH'S MERCY GREATER. ALLAH'S LOVE is
greater than your sins. Come to Islam.
Come to the religion that goes in line
with the brain that God gave you. That's
what I'M TALKING ABOUT UNIVERSAL
KNOWLEDGE. I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT
SUBJECTIVITY. Something all of us WILL
AGREE. IF I SEE A BABY, someone changes
his nappy and IS IN NEED OF HELP AND
someone tell me that is God.
Everyone knows this is a farce and this
is a blasphemy. But he already
established we should not use our brain,
just follow, just have a blind faith.
Again, that's why Christianity is dying.
So can we go back to the main point? Do
you believe Jesus is God? Does it go in
line with our sound intellect and with
the text or not?
Do you want to discuss it or not?
I knew it.
I I knew it.
I think anybody who will watch this
I lost
I lost I lost I lost all on our
intellect or not use our intellect. Our
intellect is a tool that has been given
to us by God. We are thinking creatures
with mind because we were created in the
image and likeness of God.
So my friend here has not been listening
to me at all. was not my
Second You believe that Christianity is
dying. You are wrong
I can tell
I do not come from the western world. I
come from Russia. I am from Moscow. I
live in Moscow. So
I'm only visiting England.
And what we have experienced in Russia
in the past 35 years to 40 years is a
revival of Christianity. After 70 of
Christianity. After 70 years of
communism and militant atheism, our
churches are overcrowded and packed. We
have built thousands and thousands and
thousands
thousands of churches in Russia, in our
country. So, there's young people,
adults, everybody comes to church.
People know that this is so important.
So, Christianity is not dying there and
Christianity is not dying here, either.
Because we know and we have seen in the
past few years how many young people,
how many people who already have ideas
about faith and religion have come to
the accept the Lord Jesus Christ. We in
the Orthodox Church we have a thing
called catechumens, those who are
preparing to become members of the
Orthodox Church. We have them by a
hundreds and thousands at almost every
parish in the West. Well,
>> Christianity, you come to our Orthodox
Church here in London, Russian Orthodox
Cathedral. It's in Russia, but I'm
talking about
Western but I don't No, no, no. You know
what I'm trying to get to my point. No,
now let me tell you something. So,
Christianity is not dying and certainly
Christianity is not dying because
apparently it is false. It isn't. So, I
never said that we must not rely on our
intellect. I said that the foundation
for our faith, the foundation for what
we believe is actually the teaching of
the Lord Jesus Christ and his apostles.
He is the cornerstone of our faith. He
is the foundation of on which
we build our faith. And that's why we
thought we actually follow someone who
had connection with biblical prophets.
We follow someone who did know what God
is because God himself had revealed him
in the person of the Lord Jesus Christ.
Now, do we believe in the oneness of
God? Do we believe that God is one?
Christians have been dying for the
oneness of God since the first century.
So, already in the first century there
were people among us, my brothers and
sisters in the ancient church, who would
die rather than accept anything
polytheistic. So, they believed in in
one God. They knew that there's only one
creator of the world.
is Yahweh, Jehovah, as some sometimes he
is Is that the son? Is that the son?
pronounced. So, it is the God of
Abraham, the God of Isaac, the God of
Jacob. This is the God of all the
prophets. This is the God who in the
person of his son became became
incarnate 2,000 years ago. Now,
we heard some things about Islam and
Allahu Akbar Allahu Samad lam yalid
walam yulad. We're going to We're going
to listen to Quranic verses about the
unity of God. Those guys are what we
call Unitarian monotheists. We are
Trinitarian monotheists. Thank you very
much.
>> But, it's not It's not about Unitarian
the God because as the Bible tells us
that even demons believe that God
exists. Even demons know that there's
only one God and yet they tremble. For
us it is important not so much not only
not only to believe that God is one. We
know that. That is the foundation
already before you start telling that I
say that we don't believe in the oneness
of God. What is important is to be in
union with God, to return to God, to
reestablish that bond between God and
ourselves, which was severed and
separated
when our forebears sinned, as we read
about it in the book of Genesis. So,
without God's help human beings could
not save themselves because as Leo the
Great says, we had fallen so deep that
we could not get out by ourselves. So,
God himself had to come down, put upon
himself as
to
heal it, live a perfect life, die on the
cross, and rise again on the third day.
So, this is the foundation of our faith.
Now, about Islam. No, no, before going
to Islam, we want to answer the
questions.
>> You ask those people here. You ask I
knew this is going to
be a good talk. Listen to them argue
about tawhid. Listen to them argue about
their aqidah. Listen to Salafis arguing
with the others about how many right
hands does Allah have. What is his
height? Does he have Why does he appear
in visions as a young man with no beard
in the hadith? What does all that mean?
What is our tawhid about that? What what
what what is that? What is about the
Quran? Is the Quran eternal? Was it
created or was it not created? It would
be very interesting to hear his response
because in Sunni Islam, the answer is it
is not created, but how we don't know.
So, if it's not created, then is it an
attribute of God? And if it's an
attribute of God, is it a part of God?
Or is it something separate to God? And
if it is something separate to God, then
how can it be uncreated? And if it's an
attribute of God, why don't you just
call it that? So, you see there are
fundamental differences between us, but
the main difference is that my friend
here and all his friends
belonging to the Muslim faith have
nothing to do, I'm afraid, with the
actual divine revelation manifest in the
person of the Lord
>> You keep coming close. And okay, I'm
finishing now. Honestly, I think it
would be very useful for us to have some
kind of deadline. Yeah, no, I want to
ask you.
How many gods do you believe in? I
believe in one God, the creator of the
world. Is that the father of Jesus?
Well, that's a false dichotomy. It's not
It's not It's not It's not According to
the Bible, Jesus said that I'm going to
my God and your God.
Between him and the father. And he was
I'm going to myself. If he believes that
Jesus as God is the father, all the
Christians going to call you heretic.
And also there's a point that you
mentioned I want to deal with. Brother,
if a tree has 25 branches, it's still
one tree. YOU ARGUMENT ABOUT ASH'ARI AND
SALAFI FIVE HANDS or God IS IS SO BAD
because if a tree has five branches or
have whatever have, it's still one tree.
You understand? IF IF ME HAVE FOUR
HANDS, I'm still one person. BUT IF YOU
HAVE ME and you and him, then you say we
are one person. Maybe you mean that we
have the same substance cuz I have a
human body, you have a human body, human
body. That's right. However, we are
three persons. So therefore, listen, I'm
asking you simply. If you say you
believe in one God, clearly you're going
to make yourself out of respect and
you're going to make Christians leave
Christianity.
If you believe in one God, which one?
The God that came, died on the cross, or
the one did not die? Already I'm making
a distinction. Already. So which one is
it? The one who came, without, please
I'm digressing, the one who came, died
on the cross, or the one did not come,
the father? Which one you believe in? In
the New Testament, the Lord Jesus Christ
is called the wisdom of God. He's called
the power of God. He's called the word
of God. So what does that mean exactly?
He's also called the son of God, the son
of the father. So Jesus Christ, the
second person of the Trinity, he is
He He He is eternally begotten by the
father. He's not something separate from
the father, but he is a different
hypostasis or different person as we
would use the in the Latin tradition
this term, right? So they exist
co-eternally in one divine essence, one
divine nature. Now, when we hear such a
question, "Which God do you believe in?
Do you believe in God the father, or do
you believe in God the son?" Because if
you're going to say that the son is the
father everybody's going to call you
heretic. Of course I'm not going to say
that the son is the father because we
2,000 years we have known that the son
is the son and the father is the father.
And yet the son is inseparable from the
father because he is maybe for our
Muslim friends it would be easier to
understand that in light of that
terminology that I used before that he
is the wisdom of God that he is the word
of God that he is the power of God. How
can God exist without his power?
Can God exist without his wisdom? How
can God exist without his word? You
cannot imagine God powerless.
Imagine God having no word.
You cannot imagine him without wisdom.
But he had no power. Jesus is power of
God but he had no power. We do not
interrupt him. No, but we can't just sit
here and let you speak for hours. That
is why I asked you that No, but we have
to pin down each other. I don't mind you
pinning me down. I don't mind.
Because what it seems to us outsiders is
that what they believe about the Quran
is that actually the Quran is some kind
of
uh divine word of Allah.
So, if it is the divine word of Allah
then it became incarnate. It was put on
print. It was written down, right? So,
this is what they believe. So, they
believe effectively create in in reality
that Allah's word
became manifest just in a book, right?
We don't believe that. Is it separate or
is it the same with Allah, right? So,
that's that's a question. Now, for us
we don't believe that
became a book. We believe that the word
of God, the power of God, the wisdom of
God, all those terms that are applied to
the Lord Jesus Christ and have been
applied for for for thousands of years
even before the earthly birth of the
savior.
We those those things apply to him and
How did he Is it
You have a paper?
I still I will continue to return to the
Huh? Is it time I can it? That's what I
like to do. Just
Can we pin down each other to see that
you are saying? So, now you said we
believe before we go by what we believe
because I respect you just making
yourself look more and educate person. I
respect. You know why? Cuz now if I say
I'm going home and I'm going to write it
down, does it mean my speech come out
and become a pink I mean ink. If you
start speaking I'm writing something, no
one with a sound minded person would say
his speech transfer and became ink and a
paper. What I'm utilizing and your
speech that has not left you. You
understand? What I'm utilizing is a
paper and a pen to write down what you
said. Not your speech become a paper and
a pen. Please, this is a logical
argument. But again, your Christian
already established. You cannot use
intellect. It's about faith. So, to to
go back that's what I was going to do,
right?
The point here is when you said you
believe in one God, I ask him which one
is it? He already
demonstrated to the Christians that he
doesn't believe in one God.
Cuz if you believe in one God, is it the
Father? If you if you just say the
Father and the Son, the Holy Spirit are
one God, who died on the cross?
Then he said, "No, Jesus is the POWER OF
GOD." JESUS IS POWERLESS. HOW IS THE
POWER of God? He got beat up. HE GOT
SMACKED UP. I RESPECT THIS what he said
sorry. This is what you believe by the
way. I don't I wasn't disrespecting you.
I mean the Romans they had more power
than the power OF GOD. SO, GOD JESUS IS
THE POWER OF GOD, BUT GUESS WHAT? THE
POWER OF GOD WAS POWERLESS. OKAY? THEN
HE'S GOING to say, "No, according to the
Bible
stripped himself off." It's like a suit.
He put it on, takes it off. Trousers.
What's this all about? Which doesn't
make any sense. So, again to show you
Islam
why I'm Listen, you know what he said
about Christianity not dying in Russia.
Bro, we know Russian Sunday night he was
drunk. Sunday he didn't know where he
was going if he was going to church or
another place. Come on, I respect
Russian. I respect respect them.
They do have religion, everything.
Likewise in the Western world. Go see
churches. Go Google what is happening to
churches in the UK. They're turning into
swimming pools. Yes, they're turning.
Brother, I'll take you there as well.
We bought church, turned it into a
mosque.
We bought bought a church, turned it
into a mosque. I'm giving an example.
I have respect, we're not pushing, we're
not forcing it. To go back to the main
point, to not digress. What about John
17:3? Now this is eternal life. No, no,
no, wait, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, BEFORE,
BEFORE. CLEARLY, there's distinction.
Why there's distinction? Jesus said,
"The Father is greater than I."
Jesus there's no way Father said to
Jesus, "YOU ARE MY GOD." When Jesus was
in need of help, he used to call upon
the Father. Clearly, bro, clearly. So,
again, I have respect.
You could you digress, I want to pin you
pin me down. I don't mind you pin me
down. But I want to pin you down.
The God you believe in one God or three?
Can I now respond to everything you
Without I know I'm going to ask for
everything. We started talking This is
now we know No, no, I haven't finished,
I haven't finished. Because you spoke
for long. No, no, no, I'VE FULLY NOT
FINISHED. YOU HAVEN'T FINISHED, YOU
HAVEN'T FINISHED. You haven't finished,
I haven't finished. Because you spoke
for long.
>> comes to this place and debates
Christians for I don't know how how long
have you done this? For years or months
or a long time
and not read even a single book on the
Christian doctrine, then what does it
tell us about my friend here? Because
you see, I said before that in the
Orthodox Church we have a thing called
catechumens. Those are the people who
are preparing to get baptized. We would
not get him baptized because he knows
nothing
I will never Alhamdulillah.
Baptized. I will never Alhamdulillah.
You're right, because I use intellect.
So Alhamdulillah. First he started with
a point about human speech. If I write
something down or if I say something, it
will disappear, right? It is I didn't
say it will disappear. Absolutely. Don't
use my words. Well, I mean, what did he
say? I mean, don't misquote me. I said,
"If you speak, doesn't mean your speech
became a
ink on a paper." That's what I said.
>> my words come out of my mouth and they
they disappear. They they they they they
they are lost, right? I didn't say that.
I didn't say that. I say this now. Okay,
don't misquote me then. You respond
something else. Go ahead.
Don't respond to me then.
example, St. John of Damascus in his
exact exposition of the Orthodox faith,
he says, "That is the difference between
us and the eternal God. That when we
pronounce words, they
they disappear, but for God, his word is
eternal and his word is personal." Now,
let's again talk a little bit about the
example of the Quran because I think
it's useful. You ask a Sunni Muslim
whether the Quran had been created or
uncreated. So, they will tell you no. It
was not created, which means that that
is, as they believe, the word of God,
the word of Allah, not the word of
Allah, that was not created and yet it
is there. You You can see it. You can
read it. You can listen to it. So, it's
present there, right? But yet it is an
uncreated eternal, they say, word of
God. So, we, on the other hand, we don't
believe that any book can be the word of
God in the sense that it is the eternal
manifest word of God and the Bible is
the divinely inspired
Come on, Torah. the word of God.
The
You think there's a difference between
the Bible and the Torah? Jewish people
they don't believe the same thing. They
believe Torah is the word of God. Torah
is part of the Old Testament. Is it THE
WORD OF GOD, my friend? It's It's part
of the Old Testament.
>> word of God, my friend? Of course. So,
it's the word of God. So, so how many
God do you have now? It is It is
>> YOU HAVE THE BIBLE AND JESUS AND GOD.
GOD SPOKE THEM. GOD SPOKE THEM.
God spoke them.
He's just proving my point.
And the only That's how many gods out
there.
Alhamdulillah. But, you know, you keep
pushing me, if you don't mind. Thank
you. Thank you very much. Thanks. It's
okay. They make this distinction between
the personal uncreated begotten word of
God that was incarnated 2,000 years ago
and the scriptures because the
scriptures are scriptures and the word
of God the the with the article the
ultimate word of God is the Lord Jesus
Christ himself. Now, do we believe in
one God or do we believe in two gods or
three gods? How many? Look, this is the
foundation
of our faith. This is the basics of our
faith that we believe in one God.
Anybody who comes to us and tries to
kind of scare us with the fact that
there's three divine divine co-eternal
persons within one God, they don't know
what they're talking about. They have
never read anything about the Christian
doctrine. So, the question here the true
question here is if this person here
with all respect with all respect as you
said to me with all respect, if he keeps
coming here every week and he knows
nothing about the faith that he is
debating, then why why waste time on
him? Why waste time on this propaganda
of on this junk? I try to throw the the
the towel. So,
>> I try to throw the towel. That's what I
try to do. I'm visiting England from
Russia. So, So, you have to go?
>> Love from Russia to you guys. No, I
don't have to go. Okay, so let Don't
worry. Please stay. Yeah, yeah. So, so I
come in So, which God do you believe in?
The one? The father or Jesus? He comes
here every week and he knows nothing
about Christian But teach me. Teach me.
TEACH US. LET'S TEACH US. I'm going to
Okay. Is that one God you believe? Is it
the father or Jesus?
One God I believe in is called Yahweh.
Is that the father or Jesus?
>> who created the world. That's not my
question. This is the name of the word
of God of the logos of God who became
incarnated 2,000 years ago. Where did
Jesus call himself Yahweh in the Bible?
In Mark in Mark 6 in
John in John 70 Okay, let me BECAUSE THE
WORD YAHWEH Jesus never used it.
>> called Mark he had given me this copy of
the gospel. Jesus never used the word
Yahweh by By way.
Okay? Therefore, I ask him simple
question. Which one the father of Jesus
is it Jesus? The word Yahweh As I said,
as I said, it is tragic Is that Okay.
>> their lives doing something they don't
understand.
All right. So, that's just one example,
okay? One example to you, all right?
From the Gospel of John, which was so
kindly given to me by our friend Mark.
So, you open
the Gospel of John. I don't have other
Gospels. I would have used Mark 6. I
think it's better. Okay, what?
>> use John because that's the only Gospel
I have.
So, chapter 18,
the soldiers, together with Judas, come
to arrest the Lord Jesus Christ. They
come to do what? They come to arrest
arrest him in the garden. Who do they
come to God? They come to arrest God? Is
this news to you? But
Christian, do you know God got arrested?
You see, he's not allowing me to read
this out. No, let me read it. I'm not
just I I'm shocked. God got arrested.
I'm vulnerable,
Vulnerable are those who don't know
anything what that they're doing.
Amazing. So, in in in in John 18, they
come to arrest Jesus, and they um and in
verse two,
>> 18 what? Now, Ju- just just pay
attention. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Now, Judas,
who betrayed him, knew the place because
Jesus had often met there with his
disciples.
So, Judas came But which one? guiding a
detachment of soldiers and some
officials from the chief priests and the
Pharisees. They were carrying torches,
lanterns, and weapons. So, that's now
verse four. Jesus, knowing all that was
going to happen to him, you see, he was
knowing what was going to happen to him
because this is what he came for.
Went out and asked them, "Who is it you
want?" In verse five, "Jesus of
Nazareth," they replied. And finally, in
verse five, he says, "I am he. I am he."
And Judas, the traitor, was standing
there with them. When Jesus said, "I am
he," they drew back and fell to the
ground. Now, you Let us now So, Yahweh
got arrested. That was Yahweh. He's not
Yahweh.
There's no Yahweh. The word Yahweh is
not there. Have respect.
Yahweh, that's not the word. And that's
not Jesus, by the way.
That is it.
I'm not afraid, but it doesn't say
Yahweh.
BUT YOU KEEP COMING
ISLAM IS BRINGING YOU ISLAM. To truth
you can inshallah.
No, no, no, no. So, Jesus never said
explanation.
I didn't believe
This is the same word?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's no Yahweh there, by the way.
This is explanation. You're bringing
explanation.
You're bringing explanation.
But let me talk for long. Just keep it
simple and short.
And nice.
That's what
There is. I'll show you from the Bible.
Okay. By the way, did you see, my dear
brothers and sisters, ladies and
gentlemen, my question was simple. How
many gods do you believe in? Is it the
Father or Jesus? Then he went on to say
about Yahweh. There's no word Yahweh in
the New Testament. Jesus never used it
at all. He just established my point by
saying the scholar said, "What did he
say? The scholars said, not Jesus said,
the scholars
explained it this way. So, there's no
clear passage." The other thing, Jesus
himself, if he was Yahweh, why he
saying,
"My God, my God, why you have forsaken
me?" So, Jesus, I respect as bipolar or
schizophrenia. HE HAS TWO PERSONALITIES.
HOW HE'S THE FATHER OR THE HOLY He's
God, but he said to God. Is that me,
Shamsi? And I said, "Shamsi, why you
forgetting me?" I brother, are you
Shamsi? You What happened to you? You
understand? That's why I respect you.
The Jesus, you are making Jesus look
very bad. That's why Ibn Qayyim, one of
the Islamic scholars said, "The Jesus
that goes in line with our sound
intellect, that it goes in line with the
natural inclination, is the Jesus of
Islam." Jesus of the Yahud, they of the
Jewish people, they accuse him of evil
things. The Christians, they made crazy
things about him. You understand?
Becoming a God, baby. He just SAID HE'S
THE POWER OF GOD. Then he said he's God.
Cuz God not just a power, has other
attributes. Then he talk about the the
word of God, cuz I want to refute this
argument. The Jewish people believe the
Torah is the word of God. God spoke it.
NO ONE THINKS THE BIBLE, THE TORAH YOU
HOLDING, that the word became the
word of God became the in the ink and
the paper. So, your argument is
self-refuted.
Again, please, my dear brothers and
sisters, ladies and gentlemen, read the
Quran and look how the Quran tells you
all the time, "Afala ya'qilun?" Do they
not use their brain brain? "Afala
yatadabbarun?" Do they not reflect?
Allah said about Jesus and his mother,
"Kana ya'kulani at-ta'am." Both of them
used to eat food. If you eat food, by
nature, you have to go to number two,
NUMBER ONE. THAT'S NOT THE NATURE OF THE
MOST HIGH. If Jesus is God and he was He
was GETTING ARRESTED. IMAGINE GOD
GETTING ARRESTED. Come on Christians,
bro. Come on, it's too much. YOU YOU ARE
CLEARLY DISRESPECTING THE ALMIGHTY, the
greatest, the most powerful. He
destroyed nations like nothing. But
according to him, he was scared for his
life. May Allah guide you to truth. May
Allah guide you to Islam. Come to Islam.
Come to what believe Jesus believe,
worshipping God alone. Nowhere in the
Bible Jesus God the Father said, "Jesus
help me." Always Jesus asking God for
help. NOWHERE IN THE BIBLE THAT JESUS
THE FATHER SAID, "Jesus is greater than
I." What we see in the Bible always that
Jesus referred to the Father as greater
as greater. They're going to say to you,
"No, in the Bible said Jesus said the
Father and I are one." If you read the
the the the context, he was speaking one
in purpose. How Jesus said to his
disciples, "Just you like you and I like
just me and the Father are one, you will
be one with us."
The Christian say to you, "No, Jesus
when he was on the earth, he was not
equal to God. But when he was on the day
of judgment, he will be equal to God. He
will be equal to God, okay, on the day
of judgment." Guess what? In the Bible,
on the day of judgment, Jesus said,
"People will submit to me and he will
SUBMIT TO THE FATHER."
THAT EVEN ON THE DAY OF JUDGMENT WHEN
the Jesus, according to their belief,
will have one will be 100% God, not
human being anymore, he will still
SUBMIT TO THE FATHER. AND WE KNOW no one
God doesn't not submit to no one, right?
God does not submit to no one. Do you
agree with that?
I'm waiting for you to finish. But I'm
I'm asking you. I'm waiting for you to
finish. Yes or no? Do you agree?
That clearly show us he knows that he if
he say yes, I will show him the
contradiction. Yes, everyone knows God
doesn't not submit to no one. Everything
submit to God. That's why in the Bible,
there's many passages shows you Jesus
cannot be God. Yes, he can bring you He
can bring you any clear passages from
John and other places to show you.
However, the clear passages and our
sound intellect, natural inclinations
shows us clearly Jesus cannot BE GOD.
HOW CAN YOU TRUST a man that he couldn't
SAVE HIMSELF TO SAVE YOU?
By reading the Quran, Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala. And by the way, one point I need
to mention before we conclude. One
point, he said Jesus agreed with all the
prophets. NO, THE PROPHETS OF the Old
Testament, they said God is not a man.
The prophets OF THE OLD TESTAMENT, they
believed that if you commit sin, no one
should be responsible for it.
The old the the the prophets of the Old
Testament, they never believed in
Trinity. The prophets of the Old
Testament believed anyone that is hanged
is cursed. By the way, the Christians,
do you know that your God is being
cursed? He believes that He believes
Jesus became cursed because Paul said
that. So, your God is cursed. Your God
is
is weak. Your God got BEAT UP. YOUR GOD
GOT ARRESTED. Your God It's too much.
Well, I may Allah guide you.
Alhamdulillah for Islam. Alhamdulillah
for Islam. Alhamdulillah for Islam.
BROTHER, YOU CAN
HUH? THAT'S IT. THAT'S IT. WE'LL FINISH
with him.